this season takes us outside the wall to
vGHS and into the world of inter-school
competition so their school rivalries
are against other schools there's a
whole slew of different game modes game
types that we depict that's inside the
inside the series we have a Skyrim esque
fantasy game we have mario kart sort of
battle mode we have like a weird pokemon
style 3d hologram card for those 10
people who bought so many places and I
knew drifting stuff even though even
though something is different like we
had drifting scenes but then we kind of
treated one of the drifting sequences
almost like I need for speed open world
where Ted is like finding a car since
I'm just racing it's like an open world
kind of like story when I find his car
and stuff so the law essentially the
first episode you'll find out that the
law gets he got framed or at least
accused of cheating and now he's just
down and out and he's humiliated and
then because of that the coach fled and
they get a new coach and the big
surprise that's Jenny's mom doing the
first season the kind of planted that
they had this too much it was you know
relationship and she pressured her to be
a great you know FPS player and just as
Brian and junior kind game together the
mom shows up and then for Ted you know
you get for once now that he's not just
a side character we have this whole
story about him becoming a drifter and
like well there's a really cool a true
drifter and he here this whole like
story where he gets his own car and
essentially he's like he's like growing
up to be like a man like that is growing
up he never figured out where her room
was so she digs over Ted's room and Ted
if you remember from first thing was the
RA Sookie also takes over the duties of
the floor ra so she runs into all the
various problems that entail she runs
into our main act tetanus that
antagonists this season care to by name
is Shane Pizza who is the captain of the
RTS crowd so the RTS crowd think like
Wall Street and meets American Psycho
they're all suit words fast-talking
bluetooth headset work she comes back
she goes in Cat Returns he's like always
in an existential crisis and then we set
up all the stuff for our season 3 so
they'll end of the show like really has
these big kind of story arc they'll have
in four key
48 frames second we shot the action in
the mix of 24 48 so everything inside
the game is shot like a hyper real high
frame rate 48 frames seconds just like
The Hobbit we have a player on our site
I'll play that back we have full TV
length episodes so it's season 2
consists of 6 30 to 40 minute long
television like the episodes that's a
full 50 man orchestral score which is a
lot of fun sounds really good built the
sets at YouTube stage which is a huge
thing as opposed to all location work we
built these massive school steps
basically turn this entire stage space
actually the video game high school of
course there's a continuation of
storyline more characters etc etc so the
big name that is joining our cast this
season cynthia watros who something made
those movie from lost john n is johnny's
local economy people should know amis a
big improv actor ben 10 movies like
zodiac and stuff so he plays keeps one
dad hilariously Jimmy's coast sort of
co-star I don't really start but yeah
co-star on john dies at the end chase
Williamson yep is honest Shane Pizza
easy to blame that guy that guy we also
have a slew of cameos from all over the
place we have clip lesinski from Epic
Games shows up magic climates from
Lizzie Bennet diaries of course the
whole cast Harley and everyone else here
from what I played the Dean again
Calhoun but they totally just ripped me
down to see me in a bunny suit that's
not spoilers it's in the trailer they
make a out of me I'm dumb
nah I'm kidding I like it it was fun it
was great time I don't always need to be
like a mean dirtbag but that just comes
so easily to me I was in a bunny suit
for a full day I lay out here on the
parking lot and took some Instagram
photos check it out at hardly plays on
Instagram see some photos to meet in a
bunny suit lying on the concrete if you
want that I don't think you want that
gun you might die we are totally
uninvolved with the production that's a
talk it's kind of like an urban myth at
this point urban legend we have cameos
as an opposing high school it's like
it's me Sam our friend Jake who's like I
producer for all stuff pick up our
entire team yeah we all have beards and
we're supposed to be in high scale we
all it's like this facial hair doesn't
really work in a high school sporting
setting it's like why are they so old a
story we came up with is that like we're
the prodigies of our high school in our
schools bent on trying to beat vGHS so
they've held us back for years and years
because we're like just becoming as good
as we can yeah so we still lose yeah
it's kind of like it was kind of like
going your high schools like battle of
the bands and like two-thirds of the
band is made up of people who have
already graduated like that real I
watched a couple of episodes not all of
them I gotta say I stopped watching him
because I realized that freddie is not
going to invite me to act in it and when
she was shooting the second season I
came up to him and I said Freddy when am
I going to be on the show he laughed at
my face and I said you know what Freddie
I'll come to the premiere and do this
interview and say how mad I am at you
Freddie what the hell pretty awesome I
love everything that he's creating and
I'm looking forward to see this I saw
the trailer a couple of days ago it
looks very action-packed i love video
games i love action and a lot of my
friends are in it it's one of those
ideas that like it makes me jealous that
i didn't come up with it it's really
cool it's really awesome and I like how
it's very it's very like it's it's not
crass and it's very like you know I
could show it to my cousin
cousins I could watch with my little
cousins to be afraid of their being
violent content or like them being
afraid or learning about the sex but
totally be Nickelodeon show and I don't
know why in the gluing hasn't picked it
up already and just done it pick it up
Nickelodeon what are you doing bro come
on John Nickelodeon where are you doing
with your life oh you're just sitting at
home eating your goddamn popcorn huh
with your hand down your pants touching
your erection webseries really it's I
think it's just the beginning for I mean
people really start service I mean
Netflix is really pushing your
boundaries where people don't really
links no matter as much anymore it's
really people want stories people want
to be able to follow characters they
wanna be with all things for a long
period of time the audio / only feedback
from season one of tho is longer
episodes longer if it says one more one
more and so that's exactly what this is
we found it it's like well while
originally the idea was shorter episodes
would be better for the online audience
it's like latest build it almost it
feels like to be used to 20 or 40
minutes you just feel like you have such
as leaves you wanting more and so that's
exactly where this is and so really in
terms of length in the future of it I
think it's very promising people just
want to watch think they want to what to
know what we're trying to do very much
with this with this season of a game
high school is we're trying to turn
around like what web series do we really
think that this has the potential for
because when you think web series right
now it's so it's so much baggage to it
right it's like oh this is you see this
it was good for a web series right
here's all the time and that to me is a
problem because I see the web and I see
web video as the next thing I see web is
television when cinema was around it was
cinema when theater was around it's the
new form of entertainment and nobody's
taking it seriously and we want to be
the first people to really take it
seriously and put something out there
that's like hey this is quality this is
good storytelling this is something that
you can wash and you can enjoy without
having to qualify it which is I think
most of the time what happens with
webster's
you